hello ladies and gentlemen of volunteer
park welcome to the show
give it up for yourselves for being here
tonight
thank you guys for being here uh my name
is hans kim we're gonna have a comedy
show just a reminder
please uh train your cell phones to uh
loud because we're outside and no one
gives a [ __ ]
and uh put your masks on because this is
a
2020 and we have a pandemic going on
and you know just cough uh into your
masks don't pull down your mask
to cough that's ridiculous that's what
the whole
mask is for uh i am now going to
introduce your host for the evening
please give it up for hans kim
thank you it's good to be here my name
is hans kim
i'll be hosting the show tonight uh good
to be here in seattle
uh an anarchic zone you know a
zone of anarchy i i will sell my body
for
safe passage home uh anyone who wants to
have sex sex with me uh it is possible
just as long as no one will kill me on
the way back to redmond washington where
i live in the suburbs
i already uh sold my firstborn for a
gallon of gasoline
so it's pretty tough out here being in
an
anarchic zone uh dogs taste pretty good
who else is out here uh eating dogs in
in the anarchic zone
okay um you know chihuahuas are
easy to catch but not as tasty i've
learned not as tasty
to go for the goldens jk
i'm not eating dogs that'd be terrible
because i'm asian and you know people
hate uh
hate asians when they eat dogs
you know people say that asians eat dogs
which is offensive but uh you know
it's a different culture because back in
asia we don't need dogs we just uh
in america dogs are treated like family
members but in asia we treat our family
members like family members
it's this crazy little tradition we have
where instead of buying animals
we love our grandma
uh we treat everyone better in asia
unless they're little baby asian women
in which case we throw them in the river
but everyone else we treat a lot better
um
i am uh asian or as i know this country
i'm chinese
uh i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to the japan province a
lot of my asian friends make fun of me
they're like han do you like general
tso's chicken
isn't that just a shitty americanized
version of something authentically asian
and i'm like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
the whole thing i uh i'm an asian man
which a lot of people think that asian
men have small penises
which uh even if that was true and it's
not it's pretty big but even if it was
it's not uh it's not like we'd be like
oh we got small dicks okay we'll go find
a new hobby sorry to bother you guys
no we wouldn't just give up okay we
would start studying because that's what
we do
okay we learn how to use it like a
sewing machine
all night hitachi
um asian women act like they're such hot
[ __ ] but back home we're throwing you
guys away so
who's that [ __ ] now you know you're not
a big deal
uh you know you guys act like uh you're
so much better than us
but uh i could throw on a wig and just
look like you
we look exactly the same asian men and
asian women why are you pregnant
you're hot i look like you you know you
you're bragging that you can [ __ ] white
dudes anyone can [ __ ] white dudes
i can [ __ ] white dudes everyone can
they're perverts they'll [ __ ] anything
why are you regular you [ __ ] white
dudes jesus christ
it's like uh they're the easiest people
to [ __ ] really
[Laughter]
i love white people i think having white
pride is a good thing but a lot of
people
do it incorrectly they're always into
like the nazis or the confederate flag
they're never into building a castle or
yodeling
that's not white pride that's racism
you don't have to be white to be racist
i can hate the jews
mean i don't but i could um
i i think the confederate flag is pretty
funny i think the confederate flag would
be like if a man went to his wife and i
was like hey honey remember that time i
got into that huge argument and i tried
to divorce you
yeah i'm pretty proud of that time
kind of represents who i am as a person
so that's why i got our divorce papers
tattooed on my chest
my pride um i am
uh asian uh
some of my friends were like uh dude you
got such an
asian smile and i was like oh great now
i can think about
how i'm physically different from
everyone around me every time i feel
happiness
that's a good feeling to feel
um i i try not to be a racist i love the
black panther movie because it gave
black children a hero they could finally
look up to after all this time you know
but not someone just like martin luther
king jr or malcolm x or harriet tubman
or rosa parks or george washington
carver frederick douglass
or neck and cole or michael jordan or
oprah or
obama or jackie robinson
muhammad ali joe frazier
tupac biggie oprah again
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat so congratulations
they made it when are they gonna come
out with a yellow
superhero you know the black pant the
yellow panda
those are a superhero um i think it's uh
funny that
tanner is a white person's name
tanner then what you white [ __ ]
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black frontalist
i am not racist i mean i hate people too
i just get to know them first
you hate people for their skin i hate
people for their souls
get on my level you know get
call me when you get to the internal
organs
um i i think that uh
women are very sexual in my opinion um
they're the sexiest race
in the sexiest race in the human race
definitely in the top three
way to go ladies crack in the top three
i never looked at a beautiful man and
was like holy i've never looked at a
beautiful woman and i was like holy [ __ ]
she's a gorgeous
but is there a version of her that's
bigger and hairier and has less kindness
oh i stuck that on my butthole
never happened straight as [ __ ] please
believe me
my dad does it i think uh
women are very sexy i was uh staring at
a woman
and she got mad at me because it's like
a crime or whatever
but uh it's not my fault because to me a
woman is like a beautiful sunset that
can yell at you
like a mountainside that can call the
cops
like a movie that has a boyfriend so you
can't take a picture
even though you kind of want to um
my friend was like dude we're so lucky
we're not gay can you imagine if most of
the gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to his back
and i was like whoa man can't even
imagine
they must cry all the time the gays
have no idea what that's like i was
talking to this
beautiful lady and she was like did you
know that my vagina
is a 3d printer because it can make a
baby
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer
your vagina is the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
takes nine months to print and the whole
time it's printing
it's complaining
what i look for in a 3d printer uh
needless to say i did not see any trays
that night
trailers night you can see my drag
okay miss uh so
what is your number i would like to see
your
tray and uh you know lick it with my
lips
in a sexual way i uh
i love sex uh but 99
of my sex career was so low and now i
have to have an orgasm while someone's
breathing on me
gross yeah it's like hey i know what my
name is you don't have to keep saying it
where's my office chair i'm gonna come
i just need the leather um
why are you getting my dick all sticky
you guys ever noticed that
your dick's all sticky after sex this
doesn't happen when i masturbate
a whole nother thing going on but i'm
not just a
sexual deviant i'm also a communist
i uh i like how americans will say
communism never works as if we didn't
spend billions of dollars and kill
millions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work
remember the war in vietnam
we're pretty anxious about communism not
working we're giving it 110
communism never works because whenever
people control the means of production
their democratically elected leaders
mysteriously die
and a small rebel group always finds
automatic weapons
[Music]
and look they're hitting themselves
why are you destabilizing yourself why
are you destabilizing yourself why are
you distinguishing yourself
chilly
um i am not a communist but i do support
any policies that republicans consider
communism which is whenever two or more
people gather to do something nice
i mean i think capitalism is great if
you want to do it just don't make
everyone play your stupid game
i like fortnite i don't make a grandma
play and take away her house if she
loses
jesus christ uh but uh you know i love
america
usa usa usa um
i i think you need a usa because you
can't have everyone being self-conscious
at a party
there's someone to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up you
know [ __ ] you
iraq how dare you
i have saddam hussein as your dictator
um you know like uh politics is crazy
um you know you know what's crazy is how
they censor
television they're like you can say
[ __ ] on tv but you can't say
[ __ ] you know why can i get on tv and
insult
women but i can't get on tv and insult
poop
i guess i think women are more important
than poop
like if i walk it's a more offensive
word if i'm walking down the street and
someone's like you drop something [ __ ]
i'd be very offended but if someone was
like you dropped your [ __ ] i'd be like
oh what a considerate gangster
okay homie um you can show
breasts on tv but you can't show nipples
which i don't think is effective you
know like if i see women
wearing nipple pasties that's all very
sexual and i can still jerk off to that
if i had to
for science but if i see a woman wearing
a burqa that
holes where the nipples should be i
cannot trick off to that
that just looks like a nursing ghost
it's not sexual at all which i love
um so that's just my set that's just
some comedy that i do thank you guys so
much for being here
you guys are great